une compétition d'athlétisme un peu
particulière était programmé ce dimanche
au stade maurice baquet à guyancourt une
cinquantaine d'enfants du club de
l'entente athlétique saint quentin en
yvelines a participé un déca poussins
une journée sportive dédiée aux jeunes
âgés de 6 à 12 ans donc le nom c'est à
partir du décathlon bon on regroupe dix
épreuves du décathlon pour adultes con
con mais au niveau des enfants pour
qu'ils puissent essayer toutes les
épreuves sans s'en être dans la
difficulté qu'un humain pourrait avoir
sur des vraies épreuves de décathlon
parce que c'est quand même assez
épuisant donc vous avez tous les lancers
qu'on adapte il ya toutes les courses et
tous les sons les exercices ont été
encadrés par les membres du club ces
bénévoles ont donné de précieux conseils
pour réaliser au mieux les activités le
saut à la perche était l'une des
épreuves les plus techniques de ceux des
capucins si on est droitier on met la
main droite en haut et la main gauche la
mieux au niveau de l'aisselle mais si on
est couché on met la main on met la main
gauche au dessus et la main droite de
haut niveau de risque gauche
ce qui m'a vraiment blessé à l'épaule en
guerre parce que ja et vient ici vient
le salon gars tu prends ton élan et puis
un vrai tu cours tu couvres et tu dois
aller le plus loin possible
les enfants ont pu réaliser des
performances de haut niveau sous le
regard de leurs parents là c'est super
il fait beau en plus et puis bal et la
compétition c'est bien pour eux aussi en
dehors de l'entraînement ça ni les
pousse un peu plus donc c'est bien cela
parle et se dépense et surtout ça permet
aux parents de voir ce qu'ils ont fait
tout au long de l'année donc pour ça
c'est sympa la prochaine édition du déca
poussin est prévue pour mai 2016 les
enfants maintenant un an pour
s'entraîner aux lancers à la course et
au saut